All right. Well, Stephen, I appreciate
you being here and being willing to come
and have this discussion. And thank you
to the audience as well for joining us
tonight. We're going to be discussing
whether or not the Seventh Adventist
Church truly understands Trinitarianism
and whether or not the organization
truly affirms the Trinity. But before we
get into it, Stephen, let the audience
know who you are and anything else that
you would like to share about yourself.
Yes, you mentioned my name is Stephen
Beagles and I'm a fourth generation 7th
day Adventist on both sides of my
family. Uh my mother was born to
missionary parents and she was actually
born in South Africa. She lived there
till she was seven. She had a large
family of a lot of uncles and aunts that
were born Adventists.
And my father's father was the treasurer
for the Review and Herald Publishing
Company uh for 20 years from what
1997 I'm sorry 1973 to
1992. And uh so he had a lot of inside
knowledge of what was going on in the
general conference during during his
time there. And so I got a insider view
of Seventh Day Adventist and um I can
tell you the good, the bad, and the
ugly. I'm not necessarily an apologist
for the Seventh Day Adventist Church,
but uh I will tell you the truth,
whether it's in favor of Adventism or or
not. Uh I consider myself a gospel
Adventist, and that's really just
traditional Adventism minus the
legalism. So you and I, Miles, might
agree a lot more than you think because
I I've taken it step by step through all
the fundamental doctrines and I've been
able to interpret them in a light that
streams from the cross of Christ and one
I believe is uh orthodox Christianity
and one I think that we can we we do
have a lot to offer the Protestant world
at large.
Cool. Well, thank you for sharing. Yep.
Um, thank you for sharing that. We will
maybe have you back sometime then to
talk about some of those other subjects.
Um, I'd particularly be interested in
talking about Protestantism with you.
Uh, but before we get into it, Stephen,
couple questions for you. Just
preliminary so I know um, essentially
who I'm engaging with. Um, are you a
baptized member of the SDA church?
Yes, I was baptized when I was 11 years
old in Rochester, New Hampshire.
And I'm a I'm a member in fine standing.
Cool. Okay. Have a church here in San
Antonio, Texas. The scenic kill 7th Day
Adventist Church if you want to look me
up. Cool. And do you believe just before
we get into the discussion obviously so
the audience knows because you and I
engaged on Facebook, but do you believe
that Adventists worship the same God as
Christians, other Christians?
Yes, I believe some of the are
Protestant denomination. Uh we came into
that Protestant Reformation tradition.
Okay. So that's just I I wanted to have
that out there from the outset just so
the audience understands what the
essential foundational claims are as we
get into our discussion tonight. Now,
the trinity, Stephen, is a very specific
belief. In many of the recent exchanges
that I've had with Adventists across the
board, there seems to be a big push for
a generalizing of that term, trying to
to boil it down to something less
specific and more vague, if you will.
And the reason that this is extremely
problematic is because the term itself
was coined to express or rather yeah,
specificity. The whole purpose of the
term was was coined to be very precise
and specific. So heretics within the
Christian church were spreading and and
dealing with that issue became priority
number one. And what the church learned
along the way was that language matters.
Words matter. The heretics depending on
which one they were using similar
language and words which is why the
specificity around them became and still
remains so vital. So if you've watched
content on this platform, I bring this
up constantly and this is why. So I want
to establish for you as well as the
audience what orthodox Christian
teaching on this subject is. But before
I do that, Stephen, will you explain
what you believe as an Adventist the
Trinity to
be? The Trinity doctrine is that God is
one. And you find that in the Old
Testament hero Israel, God is one. It's
the the the saying there in Judaism, God
is one. Uh also in in the New Testament,
it comes out quite clearly that God the
Father, God the Son, and God the Holy
Spirit are part of that oneness of God.
So they represent three
different aspect of God. Let's put it
that way. But they all are united in
nature and in
essence and that's the
trinity. Okay. So good. I would agree
with what you said there. What we're
going to get into now and we're going to
look at is definitions because like I
mentioned that is crucial. Now I know
the SDA church and again my my claims
tonight are going to come against
official SDA teaching if you remember in
our discussion that's what I was talking
about that's what I make my claims about
not every adventist believes or
understands this say systematically etc
but what do the official source
materials say so I agree with what you
just put forth but the first business of
order is understanding that the doctrine
of the
Trinity is not the
same as the biblical evidence for the
Trinity. Do you know the difference? No
judgment if you don't. I'm just curious.
Um, well, I would say the biblical
evidence for the Trinity is what we draw
out of the scripture. Uh, the one that
we just mentioned that God is one and
God is three.
uh there is no actual explanation in the
scripture of how that works. So when we
have the doctrine of the the trinity
that is something that was developed by
the early church fathers to kind of uh
dig down deep and to figure out what all
the fine nuances were.
uh where I think we can run into
problems though is what we expect
everyone to explain it exactly the same
way and we run into problems uh by doing
that because it really is a mystery when
you get down to it. We know God is one,
we know God is three. Uh but how that
works behind the scenes is is not
exactly clear. Uh and I think that human
logic can only go so far with that.
Okay. So, I would agree that human logic
can only go so far, but as we're going
to see as we get a little bit further
into the discussion, um I'm going to
push back on some of that just a little
bit, but you did a pretty good job. Um,
honestly, uh, so the doctrine of the
Trinity is the language and words that
the Christian church uses to accurately
describe what the Bible teaches about
the Father, Son, Holy Spirit. It's the
specific words such as trinity, person,
being, etc. We use words to accurately
describe what we find in the biblical
record because we have to try and
explain with specificity and go beyond
only using words that are in the Bible,
which the word Bible isn't in the Bible.
So, it's the same exact thing. The Bible
describes, it's a descriptor of a body
of work, a library of work, if you will.
Same sort of thing. So the biblical
evidence for the trinity is where we
look at the Bible in its entirety to see
what it says regarding Christ and his
nature, the father, the holy spirit,
their characteristics and attributes. So
this distinction is super important
because you're going to get people that
will say the word trinity, for
example, isn't found in the Bible, like
I just said, and we're aware. It's
simply shorthand terminology that we use
to not be long-winded and be specific
about what we're uh referring to. So
more importantly or specifically what
is the doctrine of the trinity put in
its most succinct boiled down
phrasiology and you've essentially
alluded to this somewhat Stephen which
is why we're then going to like I said
peel into definitions simply put the
doctrine of the trinity is that within
the one being that is God there exists
eternally three co-eternal and co- uh
equal persons namely the father the son
and the holy spirit
Now notice you mentioned the church
fathers. Notice what Augustine and John
of Damascus says regarding this. Now I
know most Adventists do not care about
what the church fathers say, but I cite
them to simply show what Christians mean
by the terms in focus. That's all. So if
the SDA church affirms the trinity, then
they should agree with what what is said
here regardless of who said it. That'd
be the genetic fallacy. Well, it's wrong
because so and so said it. Well, no. If
you're a trinitarian, then you would
agree with what's being put forth here.
So, first Augustine, this is in his uh
day trinitat on on the trinity. This is
book two. quote, "The purpose of all the
Catholic or universal commentators I've
been able to read on the divine books,
speaking of scripture, of both
testaments, who have written before me
on the Trinity, which God is, has been
to teach that according to the
scriptures, Father, Son, and Holy
Spirit, in the inseparable equality of
one substance, present a divine unity,
and therefore are not three gods, but
one God. Close
quote. Very cleancut. This was the 4th
century. The triune God is not just one
in a a mission and purpose, but also in
substance. Jumping to the 8th century.
John of Damascus, he explains what
Christians mean regarding the being or
essence of God or substance.
quote, "For there is one essence, one
goodness, one
power, one will, one
energy, one
authority, one and the same, not three
resembling each other, but one with the
same movement of all three
hypostases, which means
persons. Nor is there a difference of
will or intention or energy or
power or anything else that in us gives
rise to a real and complete division.
Therefore, neither do we call the
Father, the Son, and the Holy Spirit
three gods, but rather one God, the Holy
Trinity. Close quote.
So by one being we're referring to the
actual state of existence, the essence.
There is one power, one energy, one
authority. They're not three of those
that resemble one another, but one
singular being expressed through three
persons, which brings us to another
pivotal
point. This is what Christians mean when
using the terms person and being in this
discussion. And Stephen, when I say
Christians, I mean official Christian
source
documents, not every Christian in the
world per head like on a headcount
basis. No, I'm not saying that at
all. So I'm saying when Christians
meaning the Christian church universal,
there are source documents that we can
refer to on these things. This is what
Christians mean when using the terms
person and being in this discussion.
By
person we mean the ability to speak,
self-reflect, exhibit emotions etc. By
being we mean the mode or state of
existence. So for example, a ball has
being but not
personhood. So personhood and being are
not the same thing. But it is vitally
vitally important that it be understood
the Christian church is not saying that
the father, son, and spirit all have a
mind such that there are three
minds. Father, son, and spirit share in
one singular will and knowledge. The
distinction in persons is to denote that
the father isn't the son, the son isn't
the father, etc. Yet father, son, and
spirit are the one god. Which is why we
also have to discuss and utilize the
term being. So notice what Dr. Joel
Beaki explains in his systematic
theology regarding the term persons.
Quote, "Speaking of three centers of
consciousness seems to divide the one
and simple God into
parts. Consciousness guesses that each
person has his own distinct knowledge
and will, but the three persons of the
Trinity share one knowledge and one
will." Close quote.
So I just want to be clear for both you
Stephen and the listener. When I say
person in this context I'm talking I I'm
not talking about three
minds. I'm seeking to describe at what
level God is plural. It is at the
relational level that father, son, and
spirit are distinct. There's an
interaction and a relationship going on
there. But this does not uh negate the
singularity in being though such that
all three persons are the uh at the
ontological level the same their essence
is essentially the same. So for example
and the fathers used this uh analogy the
light proceeds from the sun in the sky
but the light is the same substance as
the source which is the sun. So the
father is the source that both the son
and the holy spirit eternally proceed
from. The light is not there without the
light rays. But the source also doesn't
exist without the light that is emitted
from it. So if the source exists so does
the light that proceeds from it. It
gives off its its light. This is what
trinitarians are getting at when we talk
of the father son and spirit possessing
the same essence or substance. Same
substance but relationally they are
distinct.
And as we're going to see, the SDA
church rejects this because the SDA
church rejects the Ning Creed, which Dr.
Beaki is essentially reiterating
regarding God being a simple being not
made up of parts or what's called divine
simplicity. They also reject eternal
procession, that the Son and the Spirit
eternally proceed from the Father,
sharing in the same substantive essence,
like I just described. They can't affirm
this because it does not fit with the
great controversy narrative. But this is
what we mean or and I mean tonight by
the terms person and being and it's why
it's necessary that both uh be used when
talking about the Holy Trinity because
they refer to two distinct aspects that
both require clarification. It isn't
simply enough to say God is three
persons which is where the SDA church
likes to draw the line but no that's not
specific enough because a tritheist
could say that same thing. You have to
have a way of distinguishing yourself
from them. So before we begin looking at
primary SDA source documentation,
Stephen, is it your belief that the SDA
church aligns with what I just
presented?
Uh yes, I I agree with everything you
just said. Now we might make minor
distinctions on here or they might have
different way of describing it, but in
essence, what you said is absolutely
right. And it's what I've been taught in
Bible school since day one that God is
one, he's three. Uh and there God is
co-eternal with each other. So they
they're distinct but never separate. Uh
what trinitarianism is not is is not
polytheism which says there are three
gods who got together when they and
formed a mission u that they can exist
apart from one another. It
isarianism which it denies God the
father, God the son and God the holy
spirit their
personality because we do see them
working differently and but together at
the same time. Uh so but in essence I
would agree with everything that you
said and um I know the church has grown
over a period of time you know up until
89 anti-trinitarian period where you had
people like Uriah Smith and Andrews
making statements that were
anti-trinitarian in nature but up to
from like 1890 to 1900 there emerged
more of a trinitarianist sentiment. uh
from 1900 to 1931 there is more of a
transition and conflict. So there was a
lot of debate going on but by 1930s when
the church had an official uh teaching
on the
subject where they actually made it a
fundamental belief and they put it into
the baptismal vows is completely
trinitarian. Uh but they don't break it
down into the fine nitty-gritty. Not
everybody, not every evidence has a
degreeology, but they do understand that
God is one, God is three. They work
together. They're co-eternal with each
other. They don't exist apart from one
another. And uh trying to dig any deeper
than that to me is
uh you're you're you're going to run
into problems because not everyone
explains it the same way.
All right. So, with that in mind, let's
look at some of the sources that you
have mentioned here. You've mentioned
some of the things that Jerry Moon
brings up in his paper, A Quest for the
Biblical Trinity, which is a very common
source that is often cited by Adventists
on this exact thing. Um, I've used this
source many, many, many times here.
Maybe you've seen me do that. Jerry Moon
for those that do not know Stephen you
may not know he is the chair of church
history at the flagship seminary Andrews
up in Berian Springs Michigan this paper
documents down the historical
development of this doctrine within the
SDA church beginning with the pioneers
to the present day first notice what he
writes
quote James White certainly did not
doubt that God is spirit John 4:24 for
but he insisted that those spiritual
beings Christ and the father are
nevertheless divine persons who have a
literal tangible
existence. They are neither unreal nor
imaginary. The trinitarian creeds he
knew of made God so abstract,
theoretical and impersonal that God was
no longer perceived as a real, caring,
loving being. For example, one
trinitarian creed that the early
Adventists quoted fairly often was that
of the Methodist Episcopal Church, Ellen
White's Church of Origin. That creed
says in part, "There is but one living
and true God, everlasting without body
or
parts." This the early Adventist
vigorously refuted, citing several
biblical passages that portrayed God as
having both body and parts. Ellen White
was also much interested in this
question. Twice in early visions of
Jesus, she asked him questions related
to the form and person of God. In one
early vision, she reported seeing a
throne and on it sat the Father and the
Son. I gazed on Jesus's countenance, she
said, and admired his lovely person.
The Father's person I could not behold,
for a cloud of glorious light covered
him. I asked Jesus if his father had a
form like himself. He said he had, but I
could not behold it. For said he, if you
should once behold the glory of his
person, you would cease to
exist. Close
quote. So just like in the present day,
the Adventist Church rejects the Nying
creed, which is the creed he is
referring to with regards to Methodism.
And Ellen White's visions are what is
used to support the pioneers appealing
to places such as Daniel 7 for example
where they claimed that Daniel being in
vision proves that God has a body by
nature because the ancient of days was
seen sitting on a throne despite
scripture saying that God is spirit and
Jesus saying that spirits do not have
flesh and bone. But what the SDA church
means by the term person Stephen is
having a literal tangible form. Ellen
White saw Jesus in vision and asked him
if God the Father had a form like
himself. And he said, "He does, but she
couldn't behold it without ceasing to
exist." But Moon
continues, quote, "The change from
Adventist rejection of the traditional
doctrine of the
Trinity to acceptance of a biblical
trinitarian doctrine was not a simple
reversal.
When James White denounced credial
trinitarianism in 1846, Ellen White
agreed with both his positive point that
the father and the son are two distinct
literal tangible persons and his
negative point that the philosophical
trinitarianism held by many did
spiritualize away the personal reality
of the father and the son. Soon after
this, she added the conviction based on
visions that both Christ and the father
have bodily form, rejecting the teaching
of one trinitarian creed that God is
without body or parts. Close quote. So
Moon showcases that the SDA church
rejects orthodox trinitarianism in favor
of what he poses a dichotomy for,
biblical trinitarianism. That is to say
that uh the orthodox Christian teaching
of the trinity is not biblical. What
they've come up with which is a novel
concept that is what is supposedly
biblical and it's based on visions not
Bible study but visions. And Ellen
confirmed for the movement that God the
father does indeed have a physical body
like Jesus by nature. And that once
again they reject the nice and creed.
And this is reaffirmed by the way in
great controversy where Ellen White
writes what quote in the beginning man
was created in the likeness of God not
only in character but in form and
feature. Close quote.
So by three persons, Stephen, the SDA
church means three physical tangible
forms that look like we do and they are
united in a mission and a purpose. So my
question for you, why then do Adventists
continue to insist that the SDA church
is trinitarian when they very clearly
reject the trinity in favor of their own
view but borrow the language?
Uh, it shows I'm muted here. Can you
hear me? Yep. Uh, Adventism does not get
their view of the Trinity from the
writings of Ellen White. We get them
from the Bible. And I've heard you also
say that Ellen White has a tendency to
put words in God's mouth. Um, which I
don't think she does, but we never
canonized Ellen White. But we don't get
our doctrine from Helen White. And I
think that's a popular
misconception. Something that I've been
trying to avoid. Uh because I don't like
to use her writings when I do Bible
study because I want people to know that
what we really do believe we get from
the
scripture. And but she does add some
detail in it. And I might agree with
some of it, I might not agree with some
of it. If it's not found in the
scripture, it's not important.
Now um we when the church develops his
doctrine, it has to be voted on in and
at by the general conference. It can't
be just the opinion of one or two people
within the denomination. However uh high
they might be up to the chain of
command. Uh the doctrine has to be
officially voted on at the general
conference and it reflects the study of
the scholars and it also reflects the
general consensus within the the the
pews. Uh so they send delegates up there
and they all vote. Uh so to say that you
know believe that God has a body
like like we do is kind of misleading
because in his essence I believe that
God is a spirit but if he chooses to
manifest himself how would he do that
into a physical
form and we kind of see in the old
testament where there was some theosum I
can't say it
theosum where the angels came down uh
theophony
u and also god did kind of when he
presented himself to Moses he presented
himself a certain way and then Jesus
said if you've seen me you've seen the
father uh so god can materialize himself
in a way that we can view him and see
him uh but uh we'll never get the full
force of his glory because I think in
our current condition we couldn't handle
it uh But to argue about whether or not
he has a physical body or not, to me
that's irrelevant. What we see in the
scripture is that God is one and that
God is three and that they're all
co-eternal and they all share the same
nature. All I can say um to go any
further than that is
speculation. Okay. So Stephen, a couple
things. So notice I didn't claim that
Ellen White originated the the teaching.
I was very specific about my words. I
actually wrote out verbatim. So I'm
going to reread it to you and let you
know what I did say. What I said was is
that pioneers like Uriah Smith for
example in his Daniel and Revelation
commentary claimed for example God does
have body and parts. And this is why
they rejected the Nying creed because as
Moon pointed out, they tried to claim,
well, no, no, no, no. We can point to
all sorts of places in scripture that
show that this isn't true. God has body
and parts. And they pointed to places
like Daniel 7. Ellen White then
functioned like she did for all the
other doctrines that got cemented in.
She then was conveniently given
allegedly a vision and the vision
confirmed they were correct. God has
body and parts. That's what I said. I
didn't say that she I know how she she
functions. We have an article on our
website and I reference it constantly. I
know I I correct people all the time on
this. Ellen White did not originate any
Seventh Day Adventist teaching. She
functioned as the conduit messenger that
God allegedly used to stamp in the
correct
understanding. So that's one. But two, I
didn't hear an answer to the question.
My question
was, why do Adventists, after what we
just read, and you even admitted it to
yourself, why do Adventists continue to
insist that the SDA church is
trinitarian when very clearly they
reject the Trinity in favor of their own
view? You said it doesn't matter if we
believe, well, if God has a body or not.
That's a different heresy. It does
matter. It does matter because Nika
responds to heresies like this which is
why God is without body and parts is a
part of trinitarian belief. The
Adventist church needs to own that they
have their own belief. That's my
contention. Not use a word that's very
specific to then take it to say, "Well,
we're just like you guys." When really
you're not, though, because you define
all these things differently because we
don't believe that God has body and
parts. And what that means is beyond
just having a physical body. It means
that God is not 50% love, 10% just, 5%
holy, etc. God is what he is. He's not a
complex being either. Uh he's not made
up of having two ears, a nose, two eyes
like I am. I'm a complex being. If you
were to part me out, I'm no longer
really a human being because you've
taken apart the composition that makes
me what I am. God is not that way.
That's what the creed is getting at. But
my question is, why does the SDA church
continue to insist that they are
trinitarian when you guys don't actually
believe the same thing that we do?
Well, we believe that we do believe in
the Trinity. We may not believe it the
same way you would express it. We don't
really believe that God has a body. Uh
in his in his purest essence and form,
he is a spirit. But he can manifest
himself in the in the physical world.
And I guess he could do that if he
wanted to. Jesus had a body. Uh in the
book of Revelation, why would God have a
throne? Why would we sit next to Christ
on his throne? If God doesn't have a
body, why would he need a throne? Uh, so
there we could, you know, some of it is
literal, some of it symbolic, and you
can kind of blur the two if you want to,
but some of the Adventists truly do not
believe that God is a human being with a
physical body like we have.
But Stephen, the the source documents
disagree with you. That's the problem.
Jerry Moon just told us what the
Adventist Church means by person is
having a literal tangible form because
if you don't, you actually believe in an
imaginary spiritualized way concept
where God's not really personal. And
this then also gets into the physicalist
worldview of Seventh Day Adventism that
if it's not having a physical tangible I
can touch it type thing, it must not
really be real. That's the worldview of
the people that formulated and
architected this worldview and this
system. It's foundational actually to
the system like we're going to see in a
little bit. But um we we'll move forward
because you're going to have more to say
and I'll have more to say obviously as
well. Um but we're going to get into
this this further because there we're
going to see why it's necessary
systematically that God does have a
physical body. It's necessary in the
system. And I know that you may
personally reject that and praise God if
you do. Um, and I know there are lots of
people out there that do. And like I
said, I'm not saying that all 7th
Adventists understand this. But
systematically, and according to the
source documentation, comprehensively,
this most certainly is what the system
teaches. It absolutely is, and it's
necessary. We'll see. But Moon continues
explaining another vital aspect of the
SDA church's present view. Notice what
he says.
Quote, her, talking about Ellen White,
her capstone statement came in 1905. So,
you alluded to this a little bit,
Stephen, regarding dates in your in your
opening. She wrote, "There are three
living persons of the heavenly trio,
three great
powers, the father, the son, and the
holy spirit." In the same year, she
defined their unity in relational rather
than philosophical terms. Quote, "The
unity that exists between Christ and his
disciples does not destroy the
personality of either. They are one in
purpose, in mind, in character, but not
in
person. It is thus that God and Christ
are one. Since Ellen White clearly held
the basic formula of one God and three
persons, it can hardly be denied that
her view is essentially trinitarian.
However, her view differs from
traditional trinitarianism in the
following important respects. Close
quote. So he recognizes that Ellen White
said the heavenly trio are three great
powers plural that does not comport with
the trinity. Furthermore, notice that he
does what I mentioned earlier, the
boiling down of a very specific term to
say, well, it can hardly be argued that
her view, which is the present Adventist
view, is essentially in trinitarian. But
then he goes on to list the plethora of
ways that it is entirely different and
it's
just basically tries to like presented
as though it's like oh these are just
kind of like nuanced differences when no
it's like foundational ones. So Stephen
again you have scholars and teachers
within your movement that are putting
out papers and openly admitting that
what Adventists mean by trinity person
etc it's different than what Christians
mean. I understand that you may say we
we can only go so far or we we shouldn't
this, we shouldn't that. But really
though, that's irrelevant to what the
Christian baseline is. The Christian
baseline is established. Whether you can
point to evangelicals out there
somewhere that are ignorant or whatever,
that'd be the equivalent of me just
pointing to, you know, fringe crackpot
SDAs and claiming, well, see, all
Adventists are this guy off in the
corner at the potlook with the ascension
robe on, you know, binging Walter Ve.
when it's like, well, no, that's not how
all Adventists are. So, Adventists
continue to insist they believe in the
same God as Christians simply because
you guys are using the same words. Do
you not think this is dishonest and that
the organization should own that they
have their own concept and then defend
that? Do you see what I'm saying? Is
that not fair?
Well, I don't think that it's fair to
say that everyone has to think the same
way on the subject because it is a
mystery and you can only go far. I said
in the beginning, human logic will only
take you so far and there are different
views of the trinity within
Protestantism and within
Catholicism. Uh, and so there there are
competing views there. that to say that
we are
anti-trinitarian is not correct because
we believe that God is one and God is
three. Uh we we reject unitarianism. We
reject
polytheism. We're not tritheists. We do
believe that God is
distinct three personalities but never
separate. And so you have God the
Father, God the Son, God the Holy
Spirit. And they all work together. uh
they all share the same nature
uh the the same spiritual essence um and
other than
getting aids um I think that's enough to
say we're trinitarian. Now there might
be those that disagree with our
presentation of
trinitarianism and we need that at a
later time but it does fall within the
definition of trinitarianism. If we
believe God is one and God is three at
the same time, we are
Yeah, but Stephen, you have to define
the terms. See, this is the issue that
we have. You're using all the same
terms, but we we we're we're just
ignoring the elephant in the room, which
is your organization tells us what they
mean by the term person, for
example. That's not compatible with
trinitarianism. There aren't multiple
definitions. It's not like, well, you're
just reiterating the same thing Jerry
Moon said in the paper. Like, well, it
can hardly be argued. Well, yes, it can
because the entire point of the term
trinity, Stephen, is to differentiate
and be very specific, not vague, not
general. It's the exact opposite.
And I would say that God is not going to
require each and every one of us to
write a 10-page essay on the Trinity in
order to get into the kingdom.
things that we can just agree to
disagree. Yeah. I'm not saying all
Christians have perfect knowledge of the
Trinity. That's not my argument. The
thesis though is you're telling me the
Seventh Day Adventist Church believes
the same thing Christians do. Yet your
own scholars are publishing papers
outright stating we don't really, but we
do use the language. That's what he's
admitting. That's what he's saying. You
may think it shouldn't be this specific,
etc., But that's really irrelevant to
the thesis. The thesis is that the 7th
Adventist Church wants us to believe
that the God of Adventism is the same
God Christians believe in. Okay. Well,
if you're going to do that, you need to
use the same terminology and definitions
that Christians are. And when we
actually look at that, you're not.
You're using the same words. And I mean
you as in the organization. I understand
you personally may disagree with that.
But again, we're talking about the
Adventist Church, the organization, and
its official sources, and they don't
check out with what you're saying.
Okay. Uh well, let me read to you the
baptismal vows, and maybe we can go for
it. Gain some clarity on that. It might
it might help you a little bit. I may uh
and baptismal vows started in 1920. This
was just a suggestion that was brought
forward by Ari Underwood. It says uh do
recognize in your baptismal vow that you
are taking upon yourself the name of the
father, of the son, and of the holy
spirit. And in in these three omnipotent
powers are pledged to you. And then the
baptismal vow of 1932 then the church
manual. Do you believe in the existence
of God as a personal being who is our
heavenly father? Do you believe in the
lord Jesus as the eternal son of God? Do
you believe in the Holy Spirit and in
his work leading you to repentance? And
then the
1941 they changed a little bit. They
said, "Do you believe in God the Father,
in his son Jesus Christ, and in the Holy
Spirit?" 1951, "Do you believe in God
the Father, in his son Jesus Christ, and
in the Holy Spirit?" Uh, in baptism of
Bell 1981, do you believe in God the
Father and his son Jesus Christ and his
holy spirit? Uh then in 2000 it says I
believe there is one God father son and
the holy spirit a unity of three
co-eternal persons.
Yeah but Stephen as Christians submit
to go ahead.
Well I was just going to say there
there's no right and I pointed this out
earlier. You have to also get into the
being of God. the Adventist church
doesn't like doing this. They like to
say, "Well, we believe in three
persons." And I understand you
personally have said, "Well, one being
as well." The Adventist church doesn't
do that. And we're about to see why. But
this is the problem. The problem is the
definition. I understand you guys use
all the right language. I understand all
that, Stephen. You haven't told me
anything about definitions, though. And
notice you said what in that vow? the
same thing that's found which we're
going to see from the quote from Ellen
White here in a moment regarding at your
baptism the three great worthies but you
got to the part in the quote where it
says three powers what does John of
Damascus tell you concerning the holy
trinity he puts forth the orthodox
Christian teaching and the the whole
thesis is you guys agree with the
orthodox Christian teaching no it's one
power it's not three powers that's why I
was saying as well that when we talk
about person we're not talking about
three centers of consciousness. That's
what you have in the great controversy
narrative. It is these three different
beings. I know you guys will say, "No,
no, it's not three beings," which I'm
going to contend, which we're going to
look at here momentarily. But
functionally, practically speaking, that
is what it is. It is three different
beings who are all united in their
desires, their will, their mission, etc.
And they are united in this plan of
redemption for mankind. And actually
we're going to see some to some it was
supposed to be the angels as well but
that part failed because they rejected
him. But
nevertheless this is a problem. You have
to get specific with definitions because
again the trinity was laid forth and
nika was laid forth for specificity. I
understand you guys want to say well we
can't go any further than this. Well
that's fine for you to to believe and to
say but the point stands then that no
it's not orthodox trinitarianism. It's
not Christianity. It's not what
Christians believe. You have to be in
line with that. You don't get to come
along 1600 years later and just say,
"Well, it's too vague." I mean, even
though millions of Christians have,
billions at this point have been
catechizing their children in this and
we understand what it is that we're
talking about, at least from an official
statement standpoint. I understand not
every Christian may um understand all
the nuances and the the depths and those
sorts of things, but um your your
thoughts on that
Well, I still don't understand how we
don't believe that God is one and God is
three. We can disagree on the
defic's only one God, creator of heaven
and earth. And then by God, you have God
the father, God the son, God the holy
spirit. And as long as you believe those
two things, you are essentially a
trinitarian.
And like I said, we can
disagree on some things and still be
Christian because we're not judged based
on what we know. We're judged by know.
And so we don't have to literally every
single word in order to understand the
simple truth. And the simple truth is
that God is one and God is good.
Right. And I understand that you're
saying that, but Stephen, you're not
defining any terms that this continues
to be the problem. I don't know if it
falls on deaf ears. I get the same thing
from from the scholars. It's like, hey,
the way you guys are defining terms
matters and they're wrong. And all we
get back is, well, but we believe God is
three persons, right? What do you mean
by persons? That's the problem. What do
you mean by God? That's the problem. We
believe God is one but
three. That it's a problem, my friend.
That's a problem. And so we we kind of
continue going around this merrygoround.
And I understand that you want it to to
to be that way. I get it. And I get
Adventists truly believe what you're
saying. I I get that. But the thesis is
if you're going to claim to believe what
Christians do, how you define the words
matters. It's not just like, well, we're
using all the same words and so because
we say the same words, that's enough.
No. That's called social trinitarianism.
That is a form of social trinitarianism.
That's not that's not what what orthodox
Christian teaching is because again it
doesn't it's not about personal opinions
or and it's we're not talking here about
does every individual Christian out
there remember we need to keep this in
the realm of official source documents
when it comes to the trinity the
standard is the ning creed that's
orthodox Christian teaching not
every you know Christian out there just
like every adventist out there isn't the
accurate representation of 7th day
Adventism per se it is the source
documents. Do you recognize that the
organization is defining the terms
person, being even the term God
differently than
Christians? I'm not aware of that
because when I personally look at it
myself, I'm saying the same thing. I can
read what the quotes that you read and I
say I agree with that. And it's what I
was taught from babyhood all the way up
until now. So we agree
uh with the trinity the doctrine that
god is one god is three. Now we're not
unitarianism. Okay the destroys the
personality of god. It's just they're
all
one but we're not polytheistic or
triththeistic where we believe that
there is three separate
beings who exist one another and could
go off on their separate ways if they
wanted. We believe that they are united
and spiritually in essence in nature but
they repent and it's three God the
father, God the son, God the holy
spirit. Now how that happens I cannot
tell
you and weak on that subject and I I'll
call you a brother in Christ as long as
you believe that God is one and God is
three. That's what my requirement is for
for being a trinitarian. Uh, now we can
splice words and we can do all of the uh
semantical going back and forth, but I
think that does more harm than good
because it just confuses
people. And God is the mystery. And if
we only can go so far before we run into
a brick
wall to know more about what your
definitions are, that way I don't know
if I know enough about your definitions
in order to be able to argue about it.
But I do consider you a brother in
Christ because I know you're
trinitarian.
My definitions are just the classical
Christian definitions. They're they're
not they're not mine because again, I
don't believe you get to come along 1600
years down the road, 2,000 years down
the road, and just completely overhaul
this. I mean, the fact that there was
argument about this in the the life of
the pioneers, the Adventist pioneers, is
one of the biggest red flags to get the
hell off of this thing and get out of
here. Like, just putting it completely
blunt with you, that is
I mean, that is I look at some of the
statements made by what are they
thinking? You know, I mean, some of the
quotations that uh Mariah Smith made
almost equating Jesus to a created
being is he and I don't know what they
were thinking, but all I know is that
there was some debate over how that how
Christ related to the father, how how
the father related to the holy spirit. I
think what they believe that Christ was
begotten at some point in time in
eternity and that um he is an emanation
from the father. uh that happened at a
certain point in time in history, but
they quickly
abandoned and but when we had an
official view, it's always been
trinitarian.
Yeah. But Stephen, the way you define I
know you keep saying that, but the way
the and I'm not saddling the modern SDA
church with the the all the pioneers. I
understand there's been change. I I know
the whole progression. I know post
desire of ages is supposed to be which
we're going to get into all that but I
want to transition here to some other
quotes and I want to ask you some some
very pointed questions about these okay
because you've made it clear you believe
this organization again the organization
remember that the organization I
understand not every individual SDA I
understand you may disagree etc I get
that we're talking organizationally so
we're looking at statements that have
authority organizationally so I want to
hear from you how this comports with
trinitarianism.
Okay, you mentioned earlier, okay, their
one being, their one
substance. Quote, Ellen White, this is
in Signs of the Times in 1900 after
Desire of Ages. Quote, Christ is the
pre-existent, selfexistent son of God.
In speaking of his pre-existence, Christ
carries the mind back through dateless
ages. Close quote.
So Christ is not self-existence,
Stephen. Existence is being. So here we
have her delineating Jesus as a distinct
being from God the Father. And this is
not a one-off. Spirit of Prophecy Volume
1. This went on to become great
controversy, not some fringe, you know,
some some letter off in a a drawer
somewhere at the White Estate. Quote,
"Satan in heaven before his rebellion
was a high and exalted angel. next in
honor to God's dear son. His
countenance, like those of the other
angels, was mild and expressive of
happiness. His forehead was high and
broad, showing a powerful intellect. Ah,
what did we hear earlier, Steven, about
form and feature? Satan has a forehead.
Apparently, his form was perfect, his
bearing noble and majestic. A special
light beamed in his countenance and
shone around him brighter and more
beautiful than around the other angels.
Yet Jesus, God's dear son, had the
preeminence over all of the angelic
host. He was one with the father before
the angels were
created. Satan was envious of Christ and
gradually assumed command which
devolved on Christ
alone. The word devolved means to
delegate from a higher authority to a
lesser authority.
The Trinity possesses the same one
single power in authority. And this is
foundational to the SDA church's great
controversy paradigm. There is no
abandoning this without the structure of
the movement system
collapsing. Same thing. It's said again
in volume two, same
book. Quote, the son of God was next in
authority to the great lawgiver.
He knew that his life alone could be
sufficient to ransom fallen man. He was
of as much more value than man as his
noble spotless character and exalted
office as commander of all the heavenly
host were above the work of man. He was
in the express image of his father not
in features
alone but in perfection of
character. Close quote. So again we see
God the father and the son both have
physical bodies.
She told us in great controversy, "Being
made in the image of God is not just in
character, but in form and
features." And she says, "Jesus was next
in
authority. This isn't trinitarianism.
Yet your movement upholds this as
divinely inspired and holding some sort
of doctrinal authority. If I want to
come join your guys' movement again, I
have to make a pledge to uphold these
writings because the same baptismal vows
that you just read from, she's included
in. She's part of the fundamental
beliefs. I have to believe this
narrative and paradigm that Jesus was
exalted to be made equal with the
father. And this whole thing that
streams down and informs why Jesus came,
the problem of evil, all of this stuff.
This is central to the whole thing. And
she says here, he was next in
authority. Testimonies for the church
volume
8. Quote, God is the father of Christ.
Christ is the son of God. to Christ has
been
given an exalted position. He has been
made equal with the
father. All the councils of God are
opened to his son. Close quote. So it
really does not get more blatant than
that. I I mean this does not comport
with trinitarianism at all. God
possesses one equal authority, power,
might, etc. One council. Jesus did not
gain access to to such by virtue of
being exalted. And this is why I said
earlier, it's vital in trinitarian
theology that one understands that the
one being possesses one singular will
and one single authority that all three
persons operate with as the one singular
being. They don't operate like a team or
like a band where you have a drummer, a
singer, a basist, and a guitarist. And
they all work together to form a one
like a a song, and it all comes together
as one thing. No, no. They're not
divided with God the father possessing
knowledge and that the father and the
spirit don't know and then brought into
councils etc. But another quote great
controversy before the entrance of evil
there was peace and joy throughout the
universe. All was in perfect harmony
with the creator's will love for God was
supreme love for one another impartial.
Christ the word the only begotten of God
was one with the eternal father. Ah here
it is one in nature in character and in
purpose. the only being in all the
universe that could enter into all the
councils and purposes of God. By Christ
the Father wrought the creation of all
heavenly beings. By him were all things
created that are in heaven, whether they
be thrones or dominions or
principalities or powers. Colossians
1:16. And to Christ equally with the
Father all heaven gave
allegiance. Close quote. So once again,
she refers to Jesus as a distinct and
separate being from God the Father. and
that he was brought into councils that
he previously did not have access to.
This does not comport with
trinitarianism. And I know Adventists
will point to this to say, see, she said
that that's they have one nature, which
further evid evidences my point that
definitions matter because as we're
going to see later, she did not mean the
same thing that Christians
do. Another quote, and these are all
again post desire of
ages. quote, "Here is where the work of
the Holy Ghost comes in after your
baptism." You mentioned this earlier.
"You are baptized in the name of the
Father, of the Son, and of the Holy
Ghost. You are raised up out of the
water to live henceforth in newness of
life, to live a new life. You are born
unto God, and you stand under the under
the sanction, the power of the three
holiest beings in heaven who are able to
keep you from falling. You are to reveal
that you are dead to sin. Your life is
hid with Christ in God." hidden with
Christ in God.
Wonderful transformation. Close quote.
Same thing. Three holiest beings and the
SDA church upholds these as
authoritative and doctrally accurate.
Same thing. Lift him up. Quote, "We're
baptized into the name of the Father and
of the Son of the Holy Ghost. And these
three great infinite
powers are united uh unitedly pledged to
work in our behalf if we cooperate with
them. We're buried with Christ in
baptism as an emblem of his death."
Close quote. Over and over and over
again. Multiple powers, three great
powers. Again, special testimonies.
Series B. Quote, "We are to cooperate
with the three highest powers in heaven,
the Father, the Son, and the Holy Ghost.
And these powers will work through us,
making us workers together with
God." Again, the Australian Union
Conference record 1907, quote, "Those
who have a baptism given by God, a
pledge of their faith in Christ and
their death of the old life of sin have
entered into covenant relation with God.
The three powers of the Godhead, the
Father, Son, and Holy Spirit are pledged
to be their strength and their efficacy
uh efficiency in their new life in
Christ Jesus." Close quote.
So, Stephen, over and over and over
again, the woman who the organization
tells us was divinely
inspired that God revealed these things
to her, she is part of the fundamental
beliefs and holds an authority when it
comes to representing the organization's
official belief. I know you said earlier
that Ellen White didn't actually really
like inform the the teaching or it was
more so rather um it was just kind of in
accordance with what was going on. Well,
that's not what Moon puts forth in his
paper. He admits that her visions helped
develop the teaching. Of course, he
includes Bible study in there, but he
includes this sort of stuff which is
supposed to confirm what is found in
scripture. And this is all late in her
life. I specifically used quotes that
are late in her life after Desire of
Ages, which also like Jerry Moon said is
supposed to be the turning point where
Adventist Christologology was corrected,
ironed out, and finalized. So, can you
please explain for us how this comports
with trinitarianism since the claim is
that the SDA church is trinitarian and
believes the same thing Christians
do? All right. Well, let's first of all
get to the authority of Ellen White. And
Ellen
White has been I' I've had a lovehate
relationship with Ellen White since day
one because I see the problems that she
creates for herself. Uh she'll be saying
one thing in one spot and then you read
a few more pages and she can almost say
the exact opposite.
You kind of have to take what she says
in the entirety and look at the history
behind it and look at who she was
writing to, why she was writing to that
person, what point she was trying to
make, and trying to figure out if
there's a better way for her to actually
say it because her writings were heavily
edited. Uh so it treats me as why people
want to make her a Bible. They they try
to put her on the same platform as the
Bible. uh and well maybe they don't want
to say say that but the divine
commentary and I believe Ellen White was
inspirational I personally do not
believe she was inspired uh I believe
her writings have authority only when
they can be proven and filtered through
the scripture now you might say that's
not in accordance with the fundamental
views uh I would say that if it's not it
should be and uh that's one of the
things I think maybe the church needs to
look at and I think we have been looking
at this. How are we supposed to read the
writings of Ellen White and and and and
look at what she says and then filter
them through scripture the other end.
And I I think if you do filter her
through scripture, there's a lot about
her that is very relevant and very
pertinent to us today as a church. But I
cannot accept everything that she says
at faith value. Um so that's one. And
two is I I think where we get hung up on
this is that you're saying that we
believe that um and the father and the
holy spirit are three separate beings as
in three separate um have three separate
bodies and why they might represent
themselves to the to us that way
essentially they are one they I don't
how else to say Um
but not three separate
beings. Okay, they're not three separate
persons but they're three separate
personalities who can emanate three
different ways. God the father, God the
son, God the holy spirit. Now if we
purport exactly to the way the Nian
creed reads I I don't know but all I
know is that essentially we are
trinitarian and we believe God is one
and God is
three and that's what we need to believe
in order to be baptized.
uh not everyone that's baptized has a
seminary degree, you know, in
trinitarianism. Uh and no one's required
to write a 10-page essay part of baptism
on how they view the trinity. And I've
also discussed there's many different
ways to explain the trinity that uh
within the Christian church. So, I'm
trying not to get too deep into the
weeds because I we can agree to disagree
about a lot of different things and
still remain within the Christian
boundary line.
Yeah, but Stephen, does that make sense?
I I get what you're saying personally,
but that does not comport with the
thesis for tonight. The thesis for
tonight is the SDA church's official
position is allegedly the same as the
Christian church's position. No, it
isn't. It is not. Please define person
and being for us. I'm not saying every
person has to have a seminary degree,
but the individuals that have concocted
up your fundamental beliefs. Your
prophetus tells us the general
conference in session is the highest
authority on planet earth. when in
session. When in session is when they've
come to the the what's formulated in the
fundamental beliefs. And I'm getting
into this topic this week, by the way,
responding to some Adventist scholars
that decided to respond to this platform
on the Trinity. And ironically, we're
actually going to bring up the minutes
from one of the GC sessions on this
specific topic where they are batting
around how to word the belief because
there is all sorts of confusion on terms
like person, being, etc. If you're
claiming that you believe the same thing
the Christian church does, it's
irrelevant what individual people are
saying because we're talking about
source documents. We've already looked
at how Jerry Moon says the SDA church
defines person as a literal tangible
form. You then come back to me and say,
"Well, Adventists don't actually believe
that." So, is Jerry Moon wrong? Is Jerry
Moon misrepresenting? What? How are we
supposed to understand his statement
when he says that the Adventist position
on God being personal is that you have a
literal tangible form, not just that you
are spirit.
Well, I'm saying that Jerry Moon does
not speak for the entire 7th Adventist
Church. Yeah, but Jerry Moon represents
official SDA teaching. Stephen, hold on.
Stephen, hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Hold
on.
Stephen, we're going to try this one
more time, friend. You're a nice guy,
but I have to get you to stay focused on
the point. Okay? I understand Jerry Moon
doesn't speak for every individual SDA.
I've already conceded that multiple
times tonight. I'll continue to concede
that. I understand. That's not why I'm
citing him. We're talking about official
stated beliefs which come from sources
of authority. You, as far as I'm aware,
are not a source of authority in
Adventism in terms of something that's
binding. And what Moon is putting forth
in his paper as a historian is the
bonafide truth about the doctrinal
development within the SDA church of
what the organization calls the Trinity.
And what he presents is that Ellen White
confirmed in
vision what the pioneers were
studying that God does have body and
parts and they pointed to places like
Daniel 7. Ellen White then gets a vision
and confirms, "Yep, that's correct. I
talked to Jesus himself and he told me
he has a form like we do and the father
has one just like he does." But you
can't behold it or you would cease to
exist. That's the official position.
That is the official position. Do do you
understand that that does not comport
with Orthodox
Christianity? That this is my this is
what I would consider the official
position of the Seventh Day Adventist
Church. I know they've upgraded to 28
fundamental beliefs, but this is the one
I was baptized under. Okay. and it's
still relevant to us
today. And number two,
um, and that's is all I can tell you
about our fundamental belief. There is
one God, Father, Son, and Holy Spirit, a
unity of three co-eternal persons. God
is immortal, all powerful, all knowing,
above all, ever present. He is infinite
and beyond human comprehension, yet
known through his self-revelation.
He is forever worthy of worship out of
service by whole creation. That's
fundamental belief number two. To me,
that's the only thing that matters. Uh
we can discuss things on a theological
level all day long. I mean, I had an
aunt that taught at Andrew University
and you
know, she had a lot of disagreements
with her other professors as well. So,
I'm trying to explain that not every
Adventist will see things the same way
on the Trinity, but that's okay as long
as you see him as one and three. That
they're not separate
gods. They're one God,
three
separate of the same God. Now, you want
to
call I don't know. I I haven't seen God
in person yet. I
will um and my purpose today was not to
make you agree with me or make you uh
make you agree with me. But
um just to hopefully we could come to
some sort of understanding as to what
you believe and what I believe and I
think I understand a little bit more
about what you believe. So my mission
is hopefully I'm a little bit closer to
explaining is that Adventists are
trinitarian and that we believe God is
one and God is three and we I'm not
going to get into the weeds. I'm just
going to say on a simple
level that is our view.
Yeah. and and and pizza sleeps faster
than
Wednesday. Whatever that means.
Well, I'm not going to get into the
weeds because it doesn't matter. Right.
Yeah. I'm not going to get into the
weeds. Well, that's an absurd statement.
Right, Stephen? See, you're you're
getting my point. The the way you use
terms matters. You you you keep
reiterating and just stating we believe
God is three persons. Stephen, I know. I
know you're claiming this. What do you
mean by person? You've told me that what
I presented, which is supported from
visions by Ellen White, which is
supposed to be how she functions for the
movement. This was supposed to be during
a period where they were getting their
dividing lines from all these pagan
Babylonians, all those Protestants out
there that don't actually know what they
believe. They're just vestigages of
Roman Catholicism. And we're the the
bastion of truth away from all that
confusion. And we have a prophet, the
spirit of prophecy, which is the
identifying mark of the remnant church.
And it defines and shows what is
actually true when we come to a
crossroads when we're studying. And that
was the crossroads they came to. And she
allegedly was given a vision that God
has a physical body by nature. This
stands in contra distinction to what
Christians believe. It doesn't matter
what individual SDA say. That doesn't
change the general facts.
And and what I'd really love for you to
do is to recognize that and recognize
that yeah, the Adventist Church believes
something different than what Christians
believe. It's just objective. It's not
it it's conclusively objective. It's
just a fact because it's based on the
source documents. It's not based on does
every Christian out there have a
seminary degree? It's not based on does
everyone out there have perfect
theological knowledge. Well, no, none of
us do. But we can define the terms that
we're using to be specific. And the
Christian church has done that because
the scriptures delineate between these
things. Person in being is not just some
arbitrary thing that the Christian
church just up and deemed like we're
going to use these words because well
we're just going to use these words. No,
they come from scripture. Hypostasis
comes from scripture. Substance essence
being Hebrews 1:3 for example. This
stuff comes from scripture. Aras was
using scripture. You've mentioned
modalism tonight for example. You're not
a you guys aren't unitarians.
Selius was using
scripture. Marshian was using scripture.
Pelagius was using scripture. All these
people were appealing to scripture. So
using vague general terms and then
saying, "Well, that's only as far as
we're going to go." That you're just
conceding there that you guys don't
believe the same thing Christians do.
What Ellen White said doesn't comport
with Orthodox Trinitarianism. Those
quotes I read do not comport with
orthodoxy.
What I could say is if we go back to the
baptism, we had Jesus in the water. We
had the Holy Spirit as a dove on his
shoulder. We had God speaking from the
heavens is my beloved son. In him I am
well pleased. So does that mean the Holy
Spirit is
a dove? That mean that Jesus has a
physical body? You know, he had physical
body. Does he still have one? We'll find
out. In the book of Revelation, it
describes him as a human
form on our thrones in heaven where
we'll sit next to him. So, I'm I'm not
sure if we want to get into all the
literalism versus
symbolism because now I think where we
run into problems here is we have an
eitheror fallacy. Either God is this or
God is that. God has a body or he
doesn't. Maybe it's both. can't maybe
sometimes he's a spirit sometimes he
represents as a body
when we get to heaven we'll find out
why I'm not going to take a bullet
you know Stephen because you understand
what I'm either or it could be a both
and and we just don't have the
comprehension to get there yeah Stephen
the the problem you're going to run into
with this is again the trinity is
something very
specific I understand you're saying for
yourself, well, I don't think this
matters or not every person believes
this or not every person has a seminary
degree. All of that is kind of red
herrings. It's really irrelevant to the
whole point. And the point is very
simple. If you believe like the
Adventist Church teaches that God the
Father, God the Son, and the Holy Spirit
all have physical tangible forms, you
then get into having issues of so
there's some form of physical matter
that's also
eternal. Their bodies are also eternal.
They are made up of parts. Ellen White
was shown in vision that God is made up
of parts and the father has a form just
like the son. This isn't trinitarianism.
That's my point. You guys just need to
own that the organization has its own
thing. I understand you personally may
reject these things and that's fine, but
it doesn't comport with the
organization's official source
documents. I I I want you to admit this.
I want you to see this and admit this
that and
debate. Well, I don't want to debate you
come on here and debate
it. I'd like to see come on here and
debate. Yes, gladly. Get it. Get it set
up. Get them to come on here. I would
love to have it happen. This is one of
my breadandbut topics. This is
Christianity 101. And my point is is not
to embarrass you. It's not to say you're
a liar or you seem like a very nice guy.
Um, my point is to say when we were
engaging on Facebook, my claims and
statements were made in light of the SDA
source documentation, not my own
personal opinion, not individual SDA's
opinions. This is answering Adventism.
So the official source documents and the
authority sources that's what informs
the organization's position not well my
my aunt was a professor here and she you
know Adventists love to appeal to for
example Dr. Deterine Raul Deteran um
because he was all big on
Christologology etc. Yet at the end of
the day Dr. Deteran still had to fall on
the side of the great controversy lie
because again this is foundational to
the system. Stephen, do you believe the
great controversy?
Well, I understand that you and I have
differences of opinion on the great
controversy. And I understand that in as
as long as differently, we're going to
come to different conclusions. And so,
it really has to be a stepby-step
process to uh we do come from different
positions and that that and that and
that's obvious. And uh you know, I'm not
you're not going to convince me, but we
can still agree to disagree in an
agreeable way. And that's what I like
about you is that we're not getting into
a fisticuffs here on on your program and
um you know this is your show and I
respect what you're saying. Uh I've read
the baptismal vows and I've read the
official fundamental beliefs of the 7th
adventist church and I've also you
you've also read something about Ellen
White where Jesus had
a man to higher status. Is is that what
you were saying?
Oh yeah, it's over and over. It says
here patriarchs and prophet it it says
there had been no change in the position
or authority of Christ. That's yeah
that's page and being a mystery of
representation claims to equality with
Christ had been made necessary
statement.
So change in the
official position of Christ there had to
be a statement. I don't know what the
problem up there was. Uh maybe God will
let me in on that when I get there. But
all I know is there was a question about
the authority of Christ in the kingdom
and God had to solve that. Uh now do I
take everything Ellen White says at face
value? Absolutely not. And there will be
a lot of evidence that will be critical
of me for doing that. But I've read the
official baptismal vows. I've read the
fundamental
beliefs. also bring my experience to it
as well that um we the traditional
adventist view has always not always
been but it is today very
trinitary and I know you you have words
uh that we might we might disagree on
but maybe we can talk about that later.
Well, right because definitions matter,
Stephen, I'm going to keep saying that
because it does. If I were to tell you
I'm a seventh day
sabotarian, but what I actually mean is
um I'm a I I go to church on the first
day and I set aside the first day as
holy. You're going to say you're not a
seventh day sabotarian. I'm going to
say, "Yeah, I am." Because in essence,
it's it's really the same thing. It's a
day and I set it aside and no, you guys
aren't gonna you guys aren't going to
accept that. But when it comes to this,
all of a sudden, it's supposed to be
this real vaguy
It's what? Because the trinity, the
trinity is a mystery. I mean, it's
recognized that there's only so far we
can go. And we run into problems when we
try to pick uh certain views that what
we need to do is just admit that God's
one and God's three and get over it.
Yeah.
Because it we do not understand it. We
do not understand it. It's beyond human
comprehension. Yeah, and I get that. But
Stephen, scripture reveals what it is
that I'm saying the SDA church is
leaving out. That's part of the problem.
That's what Augustine's quote was
getting at. This is derived from
scripture. What we mean by person is
derived from scripture. What we mean by
being is derived from scripture. It's
not saying that we understand the
mechanics exhaustively and we understand
how God can be omnisient, omnipresent,
etc. That's not what we're that's not
what I'm claiming. But the definitions
that is pulled from
scripture. Scripture does go that far.
It is revealed that far.
Yeah. The Seventh Day Adventist Church
as far as I've ever known. You can maybe
I'm wrong about it, but as far as I
know, God the Father is a
person with blood human being like we
are.
Exactly. They do not believe that.
That Stephen, that's what the sources
say. That's what the sources say. That
is what the sources say, Stephen. You're
I'm reading sources and then you're
saying, "No, Adventists don't teach
that. Adventists don't believe that."
Even though the source materials say
such you define person for us. How is
person defined? How does the Adventist
church define personality?
Personality is a personality and that
they can represent three different
little
difference. You know, like I said,
they're spirit. Well, when they
represent themselves in physical form,
which they can, they represent in
certain ways, but in essence, they are
spirit.
Yeah. And you're out of line with the
Yes. Yes, it makes sense. But Stephen,
my point is you're out of line when you
say that with the source documents. And
this is what we get. We get Adventists
that say, "No, that isn't that isn't
what Adventists teach. That's not what
Adventists teach." Yet, I have a
mountain of source documents from the
19th century, 20th century, 21st
century, and yet we're supposed to be
the ones you're I hear it constantly.
You misrepresent Adventism. You don't
know what Adventism teaches. Okay, I'm
going to read like 15 quotes here. I
read 15 quotes. Yeah, they don't mean
what you're saying. We don't actually
believe God. That that's not that's not
what was taught.
Okay, your prophetist claimed to see
this invision from God. Your prophetist
claimed to confirm this invision from
God. And outright Jerry Moon is
admitting the pioneers, which is what
you guys have built upon. And it's still
to this day, we can go to the
fundamental beliefs page. I I don't
think you're going to deny the fact that
the SDA church tries to do the only
creed but the Bible. No creed but the
Bible, right? They don't affirm the
Nining Creed. No,
we I don't know that we affirm it in
every respect because we don't believe
in eternal hell and all that. Um but
well, you don't believe that God is
without body or parts
like Jerry Moon? No, we don't. We don't
believe God parts. No, we don't believe
that. I We believe that he can manifest
himself, but we don't believe he is a
body.
Okay. Ellen White confirmed in vision.
Steven, Steven, I have to stop you
again. Ellen White supposedly confirmed
in
vision contrary to the creed saying God
is without body or parts that he does
and she was shown this as confirmation.
You're now telling me no, the Adventist
church doesn't believe that. And it
sounds like what you mean when you say
that is, well, I know a lot of
Adventists that would reject that, so
that means well that's not what
Adventism teaches. No, the source
documents, those determine what the SDA
church teaches and believes, not
individual Joemo individuals. Because
I'm telling you, I've talked with
hundreds if not thousands of Adventists
at this point in my life about this
exact subject. And when they describe
their understanding of the Trinity, it
is not what Christians believe. I
understand they use the same words, but
then when you peel back the layers
behind the definitions and what their
concept and understanding is, it is
tritheism. It's tritheism.
Well, I understand. I understand that
Adventists are not Lutheran. We're not
Baptists. We're not Episcopalians. We're
not uh you know, a lot of the other
churches. We we agree a lot of things
and we disagree on a lot of things. And
right is not Christian but not Christian
Adventist that that we believe
that's the word of God that God is the
father son God the holy spirit we
believe in the atonement I know you
don't agree with that but we do believe
in the legal atonement at the cross and
we you also believe that the benefits of
the atonement are are being met out
today which is I I completely agree with
your last video on that subject. I like
I like how you put that video together.
I thought it was very good. Uh now, do
all evidence agree on everything?
Absolutely. And there's you you'll find
a wide spectrum of liberals to
conservatives to everybody in between.
Uh so what you consider a source
document may not represent the official
view of the church. The only official
views of the church I know are the ones
the fundamental beliefs that are
published and then also in the baptismal
vows. Those are only official views that
I'm aware of. And I can tell you by
sitting in the since I was a baby what
most people believe and we most people
will believe in the
trinity. Now I don't think we'll um
describe it the same
way. I don't think we're encouraged to
because that just runs in the problem.
Yeah. Well, Stephen, I'm not talking
about a fringe source here. We're
talking about Ellen White and vision.
Ellen White is a part of the fundamental
beliefs. The statement of confidence in
her writings is voted upon by GC
delegates which is supposed to be the
highest governing body of people on the
planet when in session. They state that
she corrects inaccurate interpretations
of scripture and uplifts the normative
character of such. She did so supposedly
on Daniel chapter 7 etc. when God is
supposedly the father for example
manifests in a physical form. You
mentioned something earlier about does
Jesus still have a physical body? Well,
I would hope that you still believe
this, Stephen, because first Timothy,
for example, tells us that there is one
mediator between God and man, the man
Christ Jesus. He is still a man. He will
forever be a man, etc. But Jesus is the
unique one, the unique son of God, who
took on and upon himself human nature.
He didn't ontologically possess a body
prior to the incarnation, which is how
Ellen White describes him in the great
controversy narrative. It's Lucifer as
well. Like we just saw, he has a high
brow
ridge. Lucifer has a
forehead. He's an angel and has a
forehead. But Jesus uniquely took on
human nature at the incarnation as the
unique son of God. The father and the
spirit do not have physical bodies
ontologically. But I want to keep moving
forward here with some other sources and
see because it isn't just this area
where things do not comport. Notice
here, Signs of the Times, this is 1911.
This is after Desire of Ages. It's all
supposed to be ironed out by that point.
Quote, the eternal word gave himself. He
did not aspire to be equal with God. Did
not meditate a usurp of the throne of
the universe. See Philippians 2 5-7.
But he emptied himself, gave himself
then and there for sinners. He took the
form of a servant, becoming an angel
among the angels, that he might redeem
angels, but they would not. And when
they rejected the righteousness and life
so freely offered, he descended lower
still to those duped by Satan, fallen
man, stooping even to death, that he
might redeem of the fallen all who
desired to be redeemed and vindicate the
universe of all eternity the character
of
God. That was the work of the word of
God, the eternal logos, when he became
Michael the Archangel. When he became
Jesus, the man of Nazareth, when he was
anointed the Christ, when he died our
sacrifice on Calvary. Yet during all
this time, the host of evil with all the
baleful, deceptive, cruel devices of sin
were hurled against him, that God's
character might be marred, that the
great vindicator, redeemer might fall.
Close quote.
So the Adventist Jesus, they say here,
took on an angelic nature, not just the
role of a messenger, but an angel nature
and became Michael the Archangel. And he
did this allegedly to try and save the
angels that rebelled with Satan, but
they rejected him. So then he took on
the nature of a man to seek to res to to
redeem humanity. In doing so, he set his
divine nature aside that he received in
the pre-earth exaltation that we saw
earlier. And all of this is tied to the
great controversy narrative of the
Adventist Jesus seeking to silence
Satan's accusations against the ten
commandments etc. again in the same year
or a year later, same publication.
Quote, he talking about Jesus took the
nature of angels to repeat the first
step then in his humiliation in laying
aside his divine nature was to put on
the nature of
angels. And thus it is that we have
Jesus brought to view as Michael the
archangel, the commander of the hosts of
heaven, the captain of the host of the
Lord, and as such the armies in heaven
follow him. When he became an angel, he
bore a fitting name, even as when later
he became a man. His name befitted the
nature which he took by virtue of his
birth into our human family. That name
was Emanuel, God with us. His name as an
angel is Michael which signifies the one
who is like
God. Whatever the name that he takes in
crushing sin and rebellion, in redeeming
the lost and in restoring harmony to the
universe, that name must indicate that
God is in him and with him on the very
plain and in the very nature of the
class of beings to whom he has sent. By
living the god life on the plane of
angels of which Satan was one although
fallen he could neutralize the force of
Satan's
accusations. Thus when he became an
angel the fact must not be lost sight of
that he was God with the angels yet
living on their plane possessing their
natures and this thought is preserved in
the name that he bears as an angel.
Close quote. So, same thing said and
this demonstrates that when this
organization uses even words like God,
they do not mean the same thing that
Christians do. That as an angel with an
angelic nature, Jesus was still God on
that
plane. Is Signs of the Times an an
official source material for the
organization beyond just well, it's just
some scholar out there? Well, now it's
not just that. Now, you're talking an
official organ. But we get the Kosis
interpretation of Philippians 2 that
Jesus set his divine nature aside and
was only a man while on earth which is
still put forth by the organization to
this day. This is currently on their
website. On an article titled life,
death and resurrection of Christ. In
part they write quote Philippians 2 6
through8 says that even though Jesus is
God he set his divine nature aside and
took on human nature. Close quote.
So,
Stephen, do you believe this comports
with trinitarianism that Jesus took on
an angelic nature? Wasn't just a
messenger? I know Adventists like to
say, "No, no, no. By angel, we just mean
a title of a role like messenger." No,
no. This says he took on an angelic
nature, becoming Michael the Archangel
with the purpose of seeking to redeem
angels, but they rejected him. So then
he went even lower and took on the
nature of a man to redeem fallen
humanity. Do you believe that this
comports with
trinitarianism? Uh
no I I mean unless you want to say that
he just appeared as an angel uh but
actually became an angel then he'd be a
created being like the rest of us. Um so
but when he he became angels a human
being he did not uh lay aside his divine
nature I don't care what that screen set
up there he was both God and man at the
same time so he had a unique human
nature he was God and man at the same
time
so you know if that's what they believe
then I don't agree with
it but does that say that God is not one
or three I don't think anyone's denying
the divinity of Jesus. I I think that
everyone has always acknowledged his
divinity. They just have different ways
of coming to it. Um so we run into real
problems when we try to get into areas
we don't belong. Human beings do not
have the brain power to understand God.
He is even says in our fundamental
belief that he's beyond human
comprehension.
So, I'm not going to
speculate other than to say what the
Bible says that God is one and God is
three and that there are times when he
can manifest as, you know, in physical
form, but that his essence is a
spirit. And I um I'm saying that and I
wish an SDA would come and challenge me
because I would have something to say to
them.
Well, Stephen, you told me earlier
though that they're one in
nature. And here it's telling us that
Jesus took on an angelic nature. So,
does God the Father and the Holy Spirit
have an angelic nature?
No. That's why I don't believe Jesus
became an angel.
Okay. So, but so you're admitting then
that
Okay. Amen. Amen. It's not. So, Yep.
Perfect.
Excellent. Yep. Thank you. Thank you for
letting us know that Adventist sources
here are not in accordance with
scripture. Now, from the 7th Day
Adventist belief, fundamental beliefs
book in line with what you just said
because Stephen, you said that he was
you you affirm you said the hypothetic
union that Christ is 100% man, 100% God.
When he incarnated, he added unto
himself human nature. He did not uh put
his divine nature to the side, was only
a man and then reassume said thing after
the resurrection or something like that.
So this is from Seventh Day Adventist
believe the fundamental beliefs book the
exposition of what you said is the
standard the fundamental beliefs.
Quote Jesus asserted his omnipresence
with the asurances lo I am with you
always even to the end of the age.
Matthew 28:20 and where two or three are
gathered together in my name I am there
in the midst of them. Matthew 18:20.
Although his divinity has the natural
ability of
omnipresence, the incarnate Christ has
voluntarily limited himself in this
respect, he has chosen to be omnipresent
through the ministry of the Holy Spirit.
John
14:16-18. Close quote. So the Adventist
Jesus is not truly omnipresent. By
taking on the nature of humanity, he
limited himself in this capacity. And
this is ultimately coming from Ellen
White, of course. Desire of Ages, quote,
669, when all this stuff is supposed to
be worked out by this point. Quote, the
Holy Spirit is Christ's representative.
Yeah.
The Holy Spirit is Christ
representative.
Well, let let me finish. Let me finish
out here. The Holy Spirit is Christ's
representative, but divested of the
personality of humanity and independent
thereof. encumbered with humanity,
Christ could not be in every place
personally. Therefore, it was for their
interest that he should go to the father
and send the spirit to be his successor
on earth. No one could then have any
advantage because of his
location or his personal contact with
Christ. By the spirit, the savior would
be accessible to all. In this sense, he
would be nearer to them than if he had
not ascended on high. Close quote. So,
she contradicts herself because like
Jerry Moon recognized in his paper and
we've looked at before, Ellen White
claimed the Holy Spirit is just as much
a person as the son and the father,
meaning he has a physical tangible form
that looks like a human. Quote, "In the
1890s, when Ellen White became convinced
of the individuality and personhood of
the Holy Spirit, she referred to the
Holy Spirit in literal and tangible
terms much like those she had used in
1850 to describe the Father and the Son.
For instance, addressing the church at
Aenddale College in
1899, she declared, "The Holy Spirit,
who is as much a person as God is a
person, is walking through these grounds
unseen by human eyes. He hears every
word we utter and knows every thought of
the mind." Close quote. But in Desire of
Ages, she claims that the Holy Spirit is
Christ's representative in his physical
absence and is divested of personality
of humanity. the same thing found in the
fundamental beliefs book. So, Stephen,
please explain for us how this comports
with trinitarianism since the claim is
that the SDA church is trinitarian.
Well, what I'm getting out of this is
that, you know, God can be spirit or he
can have a physical form at the same
time. Just depends on how he decides his
essence and his very nature is a spirit.
If he wants to become material then he
can adopt whatever form he wants. Uh and
in this case you know Elli saw him as a
human being walking through the gu
walking through the
camp. Uh so that he's not spirit and
omnipresent but that he can limit
himself to one place in time if he
wants. Now human beings would have a
hard time understanding that because
we're not God but God understands that.
I mean, how can God be human and divine
at the same time is a mystery. How can
God give be sovereign and give us free
will at the same time is a mystery, you
know. How can God be merciful and just
at the same time, you
know, is a mystery. We worked it up
scriptures in the cross, you know, in
the incarnation. Uh so because God is
God's spirit absolutely is omni present.
times he connect himself to time and
place and space. Yes, he he can do that
if he wants to. Um how I don't know.
So the Adventist God can be a person but
also not be a person. He he can turn
that off. You said God can have a
interesting. Okay. So wow. So we're
talking ontology
here. Who God is ontologically. That's
not something you can turn on and off.
Do you think that God can be both be a a
person and then not be a person?
I believe so because he represents
himself as being a spirit be he's a
spirit but he can materialize in time
and space. Yeah. But that's the ontology
of of God's actual being. You're telling
us that God's being who God is
fundamentally that can change.
This is not compatible with go that far.
But that's what you just said. I'm not
I'm not going that far. Well, maybe you
just said that you misunderstood you.
Maybe I But what I'm saying earlier can
be physical and at the same time. Yes.
Yeah. Well, you said earlier that
because this discussion is happening
happening in the realm of ontology, who
God is at the being level. Because I I
keep trying to circle us back to this.
The Adventist church likes to say, "No,
we believe three
persons, right? That's not enough. What
about the being? Three persons? What
about the being?" And we just keep going
back and forth. And then we get this
sort of, well, it doesn't really matter
how we define terms as long as I use the
right words. Well, let's let's be
honest, Stephen. Adventists would not
accept that if I used all the same
terminology Adventists do, but I
completely redefined it as some other
thing. And then I went around being
like, "No, I am a Seventh Day
Sabotarian, even though I don't mean at
all the same thing Seventh Day Sabarians
do, generally speaking." And I know you
want to say, "Well, the Trinity is
different because it's a mystery." But
the whole thesis of what's being put
forth is you're telling us the Seventh
Adventist Church believes the same thing
as Christians do. And no, they don't.
I'm sorry. They they don't. You may
individually, and if you do, praise God.
I hope you get out of this movement.
This movement has nothing to offer. I
know you said earlier that 7th Aven the
Seventh Day Adventist movement has has
great things to offer to to
Protestantism, to the the universal
Catholic Church. And it I I'm sorry, but
it doesn't. It doesn't. They're not the
only Seventh Day Sabotarian group.
They're not the only group that claims
to have a prophet. They're not the only
group that claims to uphold the law of
God. They're not the only group that
claims to have the gospel, etc.
Everything that makes Seventh Adventism
unique is heretical. They're their
unlawful use of the law, the the false
trinity, the false gospel, the false
prophet, it's a false church. It's it's
full of sectarianism and division. Any
sort of unity that's that's sought to
have amongst the body of Christ, that's
supposed to affirm Satan's at work.
That's Satan. And it was foretold. Ellen
White foretold that they were all going
to unite. Oh wow. She foresaw that
Jesus's will for the Christian church is
going to happen and there's going to be
unity amongst Christians and this is
supposed to be the work of Satan. It
just it's all this big mess that all it
does is leave people confused saying
things that you're saying like, "Well,
we can't really know that." Well,
Stephen, there are are 5-year-olds at my
church that understand this. Christians
have been getting catechized in these
very basic things for a very long time.
And it's really not that complicated.
Like I said, this this remote has being.
It doesn't have personhood. You you have
to delineate and distinguish what you
mean by that. This thing has a mode of
existence, but it doesn't have a
personality. And a personality does not
necessitate a physical body. Spirits
have personality, but they don't have
flesh and bones. Jesus tells us this.
But then when when when scripture says
in in John 4:24 that God is spirit, we
see what the pioneers and modern SDA
scholarship points to, which is
essentially what James White put forth
in his book, The Personality of God,
where he tries to make this argument
that, well, God is a spirit, but he's
not just makebelieve. He's not just
imaginary. He's real, tangible, physical
by by nature, which just assumes that if
you don't have a physical, it assumes
the physicalist worldview. And so these
things do not comport. I'm sorry that
they do not comport with with orthodoxy.
And I'm glad that you admitted earlier.
I'm glad that you were you were willing
to say, "Well, what they said there was
was wrong. It's not correct." And I know
you didn't say this word, but I would
say not just wrong, but outright
heretical. Jesus doesn't have an angelic
nature. God the Father doesn't have an
angelic nature. She's already told us
earlier in the Adventist church tells
us, "Well, they they share the same
nature." Well, here you're telling us
Jesus took on an angel nature.
Yeah, that's nowhere in the Bible. I
mean, so that's completely irrelevant to
me because it doesn't really make a
difference in my salvation. I
mean, it's not it's not in the Bible, so
I can't prove it
with you're right. I don't think that um
that's biblical.
Amen. Right. So, but you're recognizing
that's what the SDA church's official
sources are saying. Signs of the Times
is an official organ of the
organization. This was being said over
and over and over again. So, I I'm glad
that that's that that you agree there.
That's not biblical. And again, I know
you didn't say this, but I would go so
far as to say it's it's outright
damnably heretical. It's a false Christ
that's warned about in 2 Corinthians 11,
namely verse three, verses 3 and 4. Um,
as well as Jesus himself in Matthew 24,
uh, warning about false Christ. But
notice from Desire of Ages another claim
the SDA church upholds and I've heard
numerous Adventist pastors try and
defend.
Quote, "Satan with his fierce
temptations rung the heart of
Jesus. The Savior could not see through
the portals of the
tomb. Hope did not present to him is
coming forth from the grave a conqueror
or tell him of the Father's acceptance
of the sacrifice. He feared that sin was
so offensive to God that their
separation was to be
eternal. Close
quote. This is blasphemous heresy. Doubt
is unbelief and unbelief is a sin.
Remember the Adventist Jesus was only a
man while on earth. Stephen, I get that
you say no, you you disagree with that.
But the sources presently on the SDA
church's website informed ultimately by
Ellen White who is an official source of
authority in the movement and Satan was
able to twist his heart while on the
cross causing him to doubt his
resurrection and if his sacrifice would
be accepted by the father. In
conjunction with this, she also says,
supposing that he was the gardener,
talking about Mary here, she begged him
if he had borne away her Lord to tell
her where he had laid him that she might
take him away. Jesus spoke to her with
with his own heavenly voice, saying,
"Mary." She was acquainted with the
tones of that dear voice and quickly
answered, "Master." And in her joy was
about to embrace him. But Jesus said,
"Touch me not, for I'm not yet ascended
to my father. But go to my brethren and
say unto them, I ascend unto my father,
and your father, and to my God, and your
God. John 20:1 17. Joyfully she hastened
to the disciples with the good news.
Jesus quickly ascended to his father to
hear from his lips that he that he
accepted the sacrifice and to receive
all power in heaven and on earth. Close
quote.
So on the cross, the Adventist Jesus
doubted his resurrection and feared that
sin was so bad that it would lead to a
total separation from the
father. This is not possible. Can I just
ask you one question because I
understand where you're coming from. Uh
how does when when Jesus said on the
cross, "My God, my God, why hast thou
forsaken me?" Y what did he mean by
that? Jesus is quoting a psalm.
Got to know the psalter. Jesus is
telling uh citing all sorts of psalms
actually from the cross. Numerous ones.
But that was foretold. And then we get
into your it depends on your he didn't
really believe that.
What do you mean he didn't really
believe it? This is why def again this
gets into why definitions
because that's where they're getting
that from. They're trying to explain why
Jesus said, "My God, my God, why hast
thou forsaken me?" Yeah. So, they're
they believe that there was some section
that happened between God and Jesus. And
Jesus was going, "What's going on? You
know, why have you forsaken me?" It was
a real it was a real separation at that
point. Um, so, but I don't think Jesus
ever doubted God, but I don't think he
understood what was going on at that
point. Yeah. So I I know the defenses
and I know the scriptures that are
appealed to. The issue again becomes
definitions Stephen because what does it
mean my God my God why hast thou
forsaken me? What we are supposed to
plug into this is what Ellen White said
that what it means was Satan was able to
twist his heart. Remember statement of
confidence in her writings. They correct
inaccurate interpretations of scripture
and uplift the normative character of
scripture.
So, this is supposed to be the details
for us to know what was really going on
there and what's really being said by
that verse. And it's supposed to be that
Satan was able to twist his heart
causing him to doubt his resurrection
and if his sacrifice would be accepted
by the father, which would be unbelief.
And the problem is is the 7th Adventist
Church does not understand both the
active and passive obedience of Jesus
Christ. and why both are necessary to
then be imputed to the sinner such that
they can meet the demands of the law
fully in Christ which is why they have a
false gospel which is something that you
would take umbrage with. This is a core
problem right here. Claiming that on the
cross, the son of God, the almighty,
yah, Jesus Christ is Yahweh. Yahweh's
mind was
twisted. Twisted. I guess I could use
the argument or try to use the argument
here that no, no, well, that's in his
humanity and that there is, you know,
you have dialitism and monop which
without getting into all of that, the
point being that's not what the text
says. All of that to say, that's not
what the text says and that's not what
the psalm was
foretelling. The father, where are you
getting from that text that what it's
saying is, "My God, my God, why have you
forsaken me?" That means Satan was able
to twist his heart, causing him to doubt
if his sacrifice would be accepted and
his resurrection because he couldn't see
through the portals of the tomb.
Well, I'm not saying that. I'm just
saying that why would Jesus say that? Or
uh are you saying that Jesus was not
tempted to doubt? Because he was tempted
uh all the way up until he died his last
breath. So I I believe Jesus was tempted
to doubt and I do believe there's a real
separation between God and Jesus that
caused him to say, "My God, my God, why
has forsaken me?" And there was a
temptation to unbelief, but he never he
never felt. So that's how I would
explain it. But you you would have a
different way to explain it. So Well,
right because I'm just Where are you
getting from my God, my God, why have
you forsaken me? That the Savior
couldn't see through the portals of the
tomb. Hope did not present to him is
coming forth from the grave a conqueror
or tell him of the father's acceptance
of the sacrifice. What where are you
getting that? is you can derive all that
from my God, my God, why have you
forsaken me? This is a psalm that's
being cited. I mean, I could I could
induce it, but I can't that
that ages. So, I have to go with what
the Bible says. I had to filter all that
through the Bible, and if it's not
scriptural, then I'll disregard it. Uh,
so, but I'm trying to see if what she
said is scriptural or not. And I can
understand uh why that Jesus was tempted
on the cross and that he there there was
an actual relation between God and his
savior because of sin. Uh I don't know
uh that Jesus couldn't see the into the
future and he he did tell the the um the
the thief on the cross you know verily I
say you will be with me in paradise. So
he did believe that much.
Well, but I'm not sure that I'm willing
to say that everything that she says is
biblical. I don't know. I have to filter
it all through the Bible. And that's
where I'm not an Adventist apologist.
I'm an Adventist reformer. And I think
that's one something I want to make
clear tonight is that if there are
Adventists that do believe this, they
should not be believing that Illinois is
the Bible.
Well, I got you. But we're talking the
organization, Stephen. you can try and
reform as much as you want. You're not
going to overcome this. Just like GI
Butler said, and and he had quite the
the the word if you go read the entire
article, um not just the quote that I
typically use, but he had quite a harsh
word for people in the movement like
yourself. He says, "The testimonies,"
and he's using that term to refer to
Ellen White's writings, "Are the
keystone to the arch. You remove that
and there's no logical stopping point
until all the special truths of our
movement are gone. The critics of our
movement understand this, but
unfortunately some of those in our own
ranks are so foolish that they don't
understand it. And that's exactly
correct because you can try and reform
the movement. You can try and make all
these these changes. And I applaud the
people that have tried to do that. There
have been lots of people before you that
have. But this isn't changing, Stephen.
This is not changing. This stuff is
foundational to the great controversy
worldview. The world view, this stuff is
authoritative in the movement. I
understand you might reject it, but it
doesn't comport. But furthermore, we
have to finish because that isn't all of
what she said there. In conjunction,
this is in in story of redemption and
desire of ages. after he
resurrects before he could receive
worship. And she uses John 20:17 to try
and support this, which she should have
done better homework and cross
referenced with the accounting in
Matthew and seen what's actually being
said here. She says that before he could
receive worship, he had to quickly
ascend to the father and hear from his
lips that his service was ac or his
sacrifice was accepted and then he
received all power in heaven and on
earth. despite Romans 1:4 saying that
the resurrection itself demonstrated the
sacrifice was accepted because if it
wouldn't have been, Jesus wouldn't have
resurrected. He would have remained dead
as a sinner like the rest of of
humanity. But that fact that he
resurrected proves that his sacrifice
was accepted. But on top of this, Jesus
is
omnisient. Going back to what I said at
the beginning around the shared mind of
God, you mentioned, for example, not
being able to see the other side of the
tomb because that's what the quote says.
I mean, Stephen, this is just one of of
many
places. Notice John 2, Jesus cleansing
the temple. Quote, "The Passover of the
Jews was at hand, and Jesus went up to
Jerusalem. In the temple, he found those
who were selling oxen and sheep and
pigeons and the money changers sitting
there. And making a whip of cords, he
drove them all out of the temple with
the sheep and the oxmen. And he poured
out the coins of the money changers and
overturned their tables. This was also
foretold
prophetically. And he told those who
sold the pigeons, "Take these things
away. Do not make my father's house a
house of trade." His disciples
remembered that it was written, this is
the prophecy, zeal for your house will
consume
me. So the Jews said to him, "What sign
do you show us for doing these things?
essentially, who are you and why? How do
you have the authority to come in here
and and behave this way? Jesus answered
them, destroy this temple and in three
days I will raise it up. The Jews then
said, "It has taken 46 years to build
this temple, and will you raise it up in
three days?" But he was speaking about
the temple of his body. When therefore
he was raised from the dead, his
disciples remembered that he had said
this and they believed the scripture and
the word that Jesus had
spoken. This is just one of many places
this idea that Jesus had to resurrect
and he's like, "Oh man, hold on. Don't
worship me." Because again, if you go to
Matthew, she clings to him. And Jesus
tells her, "Don't cling to me." And when
he talks about ascending, he's
essentially saying, "I'm still on a
divine timeline and still have things to
do. I can't do that and walk out that
timeline with you holding me down in
place." That's what the Greek is saying
there to not cling to him. So he sends
her out to take the gospel, the good
news, that Christ is risen to the
disciples. So she's sent out almost like
an evangelist, a Christian into the
world to go tell the disciples so that
he can continue going down the timeline
to eventually ascend to the father. Not
that there's going to be some secret
ascension where he has to go hear from
the lips of the father that his
sacrifice was accepted and then after
hearing that the sacrifice was accepted
and given all authority and power. Oh,
okay. So then he entered back into the
world and came back for 40 days and then
he was willing to receive homage
etc. So Stephen please explain for us
how this comports with trinitarianism
since again the claim is that the SDA
church agrees with Christians when it
comes to the trinity.
Well, what I'm saying about the trinity
is very simple is that all that is
required to be a trinitarian is that you
believe God is one and God is spirit at
the same time. You're not required to
explain all the nuances or all the
details. You just need to know that God
is one. God is spirit. And now I've gone
a little bit deeper in trying to explain
God is a spirit, but that he also
manifests himself in time and space. And
so when you have the references about
God having a body, that was his physical
manifestation of himself. Uh but in his
essence, in his nature, he's spirit. So
God can both have be spirit and he can
have a a physical body, you know, at the
same time. Now, you know, that's a
mystery, isn't it? Um, now we're also
talking about
um the authority of Ellen White and I'm
just tell I'm here to tell you that we
as the Adventists have always put the
Bible first. I know that people don't
believe that and there are individual
Adventists
uh want to put Ellen White on equal
status to the Bible. But um it says here
the holy scriptures old and new
testament are the written word of God
given by divine inspiration through holy
men of God who spoke and wrote as they
were moved by the Holy Spirit. In this
word God is committed to man and now is
necessary for salvation. The holy
scriptures are the infallible revelation
of his will, the understanding of
character, the test of experience, the
authoritative revealer of doctrines, and
the trustworthy records of God's acts in
history. And so the authority that we
give Ellen White is only in agreement
with the Bible. Now, the way they get
around that is they say Ellen White is
never in disagreement with with the
Bible. Uh I happen to have found places
where she does disagree with the Bible.
So I had to deal with that myself early
on and say well I cannot make her equal
to scripture. Uh I have to make her a
lesser light that points towards the
Bible and if she's not in accordance
with scripture that I can disregard with
what she's saying. Um so I don't have to
believe everything Ellen White says at
face value.
Uh, and I don't believe the church
believes that officially either because
they want they will selectively enforce
certain things and disregard other
things. And I've seen that happen over
and over again official level. Um,
Stephen, Stephen, Stephen, we're going
around. We're going around. Well, hold
on. Hold on. We're going around and
around in circles here.
Who says the way you define the Trinity
is the standard? That's just begging the
question. You're using a term that has a
distinct
meaning, redefining it, and then
claiming that's the new
standard. How do you not see the issue
with this? That that's dishonest. This
is supposed to be the commandmentkeeping
church. I'm telling you
what I'm telling you what my definition
is of the Trinity, right? But Stephen,
we're talking about the organization.
We're talking about the organization.
You knew this before we started the
discussion, not your own personal views.
Because Stephen, I could bring another
Adventist on here that says the pioneers
had it correct. The present day church
is apostatized and I'm part of the
remnant within the remnant and they
would tell me the same thing. Yes,
that's not what has to define the
standards. The official sources have to
define that sort of stuff. And when we
look at those, they don't align with
what the trinity is.
There is a problem right now with
anti-trinitarian sentiment trying to
make its way back into the church and
I'm going to fight that. If they ever
do, let me know because I will
dysfellowship myself that same day.
Okay, Stephen, you but you guys aren't
supposed to have you guys aren't
supposed to
non-turnian then I will dysfellowship
myself. But I personally believe and
everything I've read the fundamental
beliefs. I've read the baptismal vows. I
know what my experiences are. I know
what my history is through education.
Okay. I've never been taught
anti-trinitarianism in the 7th Adventist
church. Yeah. But again, Stephen, it's
definitions. You keep using the word
trinity, God, nature, person, but but
you don't want to get into defining
those. And when you do, you give us your
own personal definition when the whole
stated thesis of this is the
organization. And I think it highlights
for people to see the level of confusion
that exists within the movement. You
guys aren't supposed to have any
theological division. You guys have the
theological God particle, the great
controversy theme, the theory of
everything, the mind of God. Is Herbert
Douglas not a qualified
source, right? So why do they make this
insane claim and then publish this this
stuff? This is what's in the official
sources. Does this not concern you that
you're part of an organization that says
these things? This is one of the most
grandiose statements I've ever heard
anyone ever make ever in the whole
world. We have the mind of God, the
theory of everything. And it's the
equivalent of Stephen Hawkings God
particle. We only have it. We didn't we
didn't dis He said we we didn't discover
this. We were given this. And we were
given this through Ellen White, who
supposedly got visions that confirmed
all this stuff.
You guys aren't supposed to have
theological division. Not everything
Ellen White says. No, I wish that was
true. Not the case. We know that
there's liberal abism, there's
mainstream
absism, and there's subgroups of each
one. Uh that's Babylon, Stephen, when
you try to pin us down on what we
believe, you're you're gonna get, you
know, a 100 different viewpoints on the
subject. I understand that and I wish
that would because that frustrates the
heck out of me. And that's one of the
reasons why as a child growing up, I was
almost, you know, I did not know who to
do do I believe Herbert Douglas or do I
believe Morris Vendon or do I believe
Mark Finley? Do I believe Doug Bachelor?
They all have different ways of
explaining things. I had to go back to
the scripture and find out what does the
Adventist church fundamentally agree
with the Bible. And I believe that we do
believe the Bible is the word of God. We
do believe in the atonement
righteousness by faith. And I know
people that disagree uh with me saying
that. But I can prove from the scripture
those things and that that's what I was
taught growing up. But there are a lot
of there there is confusion in the
church. And I that's one of the reasons
why I'm doing this program with you
today is to maybe alleviate some of
that. If the Adventist church does not
believe in the Trinity, which I believe
it does, it should believe in the
Trinity. And I agree with your
definition. So I'm I'm I don't see where
we disagree a lot on a personal level.
Uh I think the disagreement is how we
present it as an organization. And I
think we could do both.
Yeah, Stephen, you're you guys are
supposed to have the spirit of prophecy,
which is supposed to be the antidote to
all that
confusion. That's supposed to be the
whole one of the hallmark identifying
signs that you're a the remnant
church. You guys aren't supposed to have
any of that. Ellen White said, "I can
show you that. I can show you all the
source documentation on this too where
they're claiming that we'll have far
more unity than any creed ever brought
to any Christians when in reality I'm
sorry Stephen but no you don't. You guys
don't have more unity than Christians.
It's almost laughable. It's almost
laughable. It is one of the most divided
doctrinally confused divided messes that
has really just confused more people. It
emphasizes sectarianism. It's rooted
into the movement at a foundational
level that this is some sort of end
times. You know, right before Jesus
comes, there's going to be this uniting
of Protestants and Catholics. Yeah, I
hope that happens. I want unity. Now,
I'm not saying in spite of serious grave
differences that we just put those
aside, etc. But I actually pray for the
unity of the Christian church. Yet,
Adventism as a movement is going to is
going to say, "See, that's evidence that
Ellen White was correct. There's going
to be this uniting against Seventh Day
Adventism emphasizing sectarianism.
You guys aren't supposed to have any of
that division and all that stuff is
connected.
Well, and then I turn on the TV and I
watch the Trinity Broadcasting Network
and
Oakit and Ruth Myers and all these, you
know. Yeah, they're heretics. It's a
worldwide global
Christianity itself is under and um it's
horrible. Uh now if I really believe
that the Adventist church was not
trinitarian, I would leave. I I I've
told you that if if if I think that uh
they t Jesus was a created being, I
would leave. uh but honestly at the core
of my being because I the fundamental
beliefs you know the baptismal vows the
way I was raised you know and I
I at the core we are
solidly uh that's something that Walter
Martin recognized even though um there
was some push back within the church
they didn't want to be part of the
evangelical community they wanted to be
by themselves so they pushed them back
out. Um, which I think they did
themselves a big disservice by doing
that. But Walter Martin was on our side.
Yeah, he he started to change his tune
on that.
We have an article on that on our site
talking about the Walter Pass. I know
Adventist I know Adventist.
Yeah. No, after the church pushed them
out because you know of of what happened
to Desmond Ford and also
everyone that upheld questions on aside
and says you know what
you don't want to be part of the
evangelical community and I think that
was the wrong move to make.
Yeah. Well, Walter Martin started coming
around when Walter Martin became aware
of sources that he wasn't previously
aware of, and he didn't take his own
advice of scaling the language barrier,
which circles us right back to my
primary point. Definitions matter.
Stephen, I've shown this before and I
will continue to do so.
Despite Adventist scholars like Jud
Lake, as we're going to as we're going
to see uh this later this week, his
taking umbrage with this,
this visually proves the point and is in
accordance with the
plethora hold up. Hold up, Stephen. Hold
up. Hold up.
Visually, it proves the point and is in
accordance with the plethora of
statements that we have looked at
tonight.
Ellen claimed Jesus is the
self-existent
one, the only being that could be let
into the councils of God. She used the
terms person and being
interchangeably. The heavenly trio,
according to the Adventist Church's
website,
adventist.org/trinity, the heavenly trio
is like a team that is working on a
common mission and goal. And because
they're united in that, that makes them
one God. This is the same thing that
Jerry Moon puts forth in his paper that
if they weren't united in their mission
and purpose, that would be polytheism,
like the pantheon of gods where they're
clawing for ultimate power. But because
the heavenly trio is united in that,
that makes them one God.
But according to Christian teaching like
we saw with Augustine and John of
Damascus, the onlogical oneness of God
is fundamentally what makes God the only
God. The relational and operational
oneness such as being united in
creation, the plan of redemption, etc.
That is downstream from the singularity
in being. There is no way to hold on to
an ontological unity in the Adventist
system because the great controversy
narrative is fundamental to Adventist
theology proper. All the stuff about
Satan becoming jealous and attacking the
ten commandments that is upstream from
why the SDA church teaches and claims
Jesus incarnated, what he came to do,
etc. There is no removing that from the
system without the whole thing
collapsing. And I know that Stephen
mentioned like Adventists like to do. We
have an article on this on our website
that on patriarchs and prophets pages 36
and 37 she claims that this exaltation
didn't lead to any actual change. Yeah,
I will challenge any Adventist in the
world on that claim. And we will walk
through it and show on the timeline why
this is problematic because first and
foremost it all supposedly came from
God. All of it. Which is a problem in
and of itself. Now, the point being,
while many in the movement are
well-meaning people, like yourself,
Stephen, you seem like a super nice guy.
Nothing against you personally. You've
been very cordial. I've enjoyed the
discussion with you. But people can be
sincere and be sincerely wrong. And what
this organization calls the Trinity is
not. You don't get to come along, 1600
years down the road and redefine things,
but then use the same terms and insist
that you mean the same thing. This is
deceptive and dishonest. The SDA
movement needs to own that they have
their own concept and belief and then
defend that. Stand by it. Don't try and
play both sides of the field and and be
like, "Well, we outright reject the Ning
Creed and we outright reject that God
doesn't have body and parts and we
outright reject the way they define
person and we define it based on what
was confirmed through Ellen White's
visions, which is that God the Father,
Son, and Spirit have physical tangible
form, etc. But we're not going to get
into any of that stuff because we use
the right words." Well, it's
fundamentally the same thing. No, this
is dishonest and Adventists need to stop
doing that. Stephen, I appreciate you
being here. I'll let you share any final
thoughts that you'd like to before we
wrap things up and shut things down.
All right. Uh, well, the I've gone over
the fundamental beliefs that we teach as
a church. I've gone over the baptism and
we've kind of did done some discussion
about what we believe about the trinity
that god is one and three at the same
time. Not three separate gods but uh but
distinct. Not separate but distinct. Uh
that's very very important. Um and that
I also believe that we're not saved by
what we know, we're saved by who we
know. And I want to ask you the question
um can we have a disagreement on the
trinity on how we explain things and
still be Christian? I believe yes you
can have a disagreement and still be a
Christian. You might arrive at things a
little bit differently, but as long as
you believe that God is one and God is
three as the scriptures say um and that
you believe that Jesus is the only uh
but Lord and Savior of your life and
that the only condition for salvation is
simple faith and trust in him. Uh you
can do you can disagree on certain
things and still be Christian. So I
don't think that this discussion today
rises to heresy. I think we have two
different points of view. I think that
we have two Christians talking and and
discussing the very very complex and
difficult subject. Uh one that human
beings have never been able to
completely figure out. Uh in the words
of CS Lewis, he said once he says, "I
don't know how the atonement works. I
know that it works." And I'm here to
tell you, uh, I don't know how the
Trinity works, but I know that it works.
God is one. God is three. That's
biblical. It's what I stand on. And I
believe that's what I've been taught my
entire life growing up within the
Seventh Adventist
Church. If there are evidence out there,
they do, you should, and this is where
Miles and I agree. We agree on the
Trinity. I know he thinks we don't. Uh
but on a personal level, I don't uh he
hasn't said anything I disagree with
other than the fact that Adventists are
not Christian. I I I believe we are
firmly Christian. We're rooted in the
historical Christian faith.
And well, we there are a lot of critics
over there that want
to, you know, argue the point and argue
fine details, but
uh I I I grew up in the church. I know
what the church teaches. I know what I
believe. And um I 100% believe the
Seventh Day Adventist is a Christian
denomination. And I've I've I've had a
wonderful discussion with Miles. And
um I hope I haven't come across as being
pushy or obstinate. I'm I'm trying to
understand what he's saying. I'm not
trying to be overly uh argumentative.
Uh I'm I'm just trying to explain what I
believe as an individual 7th Adventist
and what I believe the church teaches.
Uh but thank you very much much Miles
for having me on. It's been a wonderful
discussion.
Yeah Stephen, anytime. Thank you for
being here. Maybe you can come back
sometime. We can talk about a different
subject in a similar fashion if you'd
like. Thank you again for being
here. All right, folks. What he said
there at the tail end is exactly the
point. And Stephen, I could not agree
more. You don't have to be a theologian.
I always talk about on this platform all
the
time. The gospel is the power of God to
salvation. The gospel is not systematic
theology. I don't think people have to
have perfect knowledge to be saved.
Perfect knowledge does not save
people. Being united to the true Christ,
however, does. And it does matter who
your faith is placed in. And if you're
an Adventist, I know Stephen said he
rejects those things. And I'm glad he
was willing to be forthright about that
and say, "Yep, what they're teaching
there is not
biblical. Thank
you. They have the theological God
particle theory of everything. Jesus has
an angel nature." Okay.
But if you are an Adventist and you
believe in the Jesus that is put forth
in the desire of ages, the great
controversy etc. that Jesus cannot save
you. That Jesus not is not
real. It is a false Christ. And Paul
tells us in 2 Corinthians 11, there are
such thing as things as false Christs
and false spirits and false
gospels. You have to have the correct
God and his gospel. It is a twofor one
deal.
You can't have one without the
other. Two for one
deal. And your faith is only as good as
who you place it
in. Jesus was not exalted, be made equal
with the father such that Lucifer became
jealous and began waging war against God
and his law. Now there's a great
controversy playing out that's like some
divine cosmic politics where Jesus and
Satan are in this arm wrestling match
and Jesus came to silence Satan and
demonstrate to all these watching beings
and and universes or worlds rather that
the law can be kept and that God is who
he says he is and seven steps through
the sanctuary and just all this stuff
all this stuff is all brought to the
Bible. It's not found in the Bible.
You're not going to find any of this
pre-earth origin story in the Bible. Yet
this stuff is damnably heretical. It's a
false Christ. This
matters. It's not just
mere definitions like, "Oh, well,
because we say Jesus, that's good
enough. Oh, because we say Trinity,
that's good enough." No. The thesis of
tonight and the lesson for
tonight is that definitions matter. The
way you define things matters.
What you mean by the words that you say
matters, not just that you say the right
words. And as we saw tonight, and I
think Stephen
knows, the organizational source
documents, whether it's a scholar,
whether it's a the prophetus, whether
it's an official organ, Signs of the
Times, whether it's the Adventist
Church's website, the fundamental
beliefs exposition book, I mean, we
could have kept going. This is only
scratching the surface on all of these
topics.
I've got documents, folks, hundreds of
pages of
quotes from all these sources, all these
different periods of time. It doesn't
fundamentally change. It's just a new
window dressing. It's just using
different words. I've been citing, for
example, more recently, and I'm going to
keep citing it now since the Adventist
scholars want to tell us this is just
this new staple work, salvation,
contours of adventiology.
It's the same thing as Beachch's
Dimensions and Salvation from the 70s.
It's just repackaged in like a new
veneer. This idea that it's all
fundamentally different. It's just we
really have it figured out now. It's
like everything is supposedly that. Yet
time goes on and now they need the pre
present truth magic wand to clean things
up. It's just it's forever changing.
It's a malaise. It's a confused mess
because at the end of the day, God
wasn't behind all this, folks.
Christians know who they worship. This
is fundamental Christian
teaching. It's fundamental. I'm
sorry. Pointing to TBN and heretic TV
televangelists as though that's some
sort
of what? They don't claim to have the
theological God
particle. They don't claim the these
things are categorically different. This
organization claims to have the mind of
God.
That's just Herb Douglas's opinion. No,
it's not. It's in Ministry magazine.
They show this in multiple places from
more people than just Herbert
Douglas. This is foundational to the
Adventist system. It's crazy the arc
that this movement is on. You're talking
about a movement that rose up and knew
exactly who they were, were unashamed of
it. They were willing to just put it out
there, let the chips fall where they
may, and shoot it straight down the pipe
to now being allegedly this massive
tent. We don't really know what an
Adventist is. It's just this general
malaise of well, whatever you believe.
It's just kind of crazy the arc the
movement's on. Folks, if you're an
Adventist, we don't hate you.
or challenging you to dig into these
things a lot more deeply to wrestle with
the sort of cognitive dissonance that
has to be embraced for all of this to
work. Jesus is the self-existent son of
God. Well, no, he's not. That's not how
this works. And the fact that they were
struggling on these foundational things
shows they're not attached to the church
in history. This was dealt with folks in
like third century, 2nd century and and
we can go back before then too. We're
talking about when it was
systematized. We've got statements from
Ignatius who knew the apostles
laying this stuff out and as time is
progressing heretics are
splintering being sectarians basically
and this stuff got hammered out with
more specificity. The whole point of the
term trinity, the doctrine of the
trinity is exactly that. It is to be
very precise. The Adventist Church
rejects it. I'm sorry. They do. They use
all the same language. They do not
believe the same thing. They reject
divine simplicity. They reject the
eternal procession of the son and the
spirit from the
father. Consistently speaking, they have
to reject the onlogical oneness of God
because again, you have Jesus being
given an authority he didn't possess.
You're referring to God as three
powers. None of this stuff comports.
It's just at every step of the road,
they don't know what they're talking
about, and they're trying to figure this
stuff out. Yet, we're supposed to
believe this is who the true God raised
up to restore his church. They didn't
even know who he was. They were
espousing a bunch of damnable heresies.
And oh, well, they got it cleaned up
eventually, kind of. And that's who God
raised up to it. Just folks, at a
certain point, you got to give it up.
You got to give it
up. Thank you for being here tonight. I
hope that this was beneficial. I know it
was an anomalous Sunday evening stream.
This was great. If you're an Adventist
and you would like to do something
similar and you'd like to challenge the
claims that I have made or that you've
heard from this platform, reach out to
us and we can potentially get it set up
in the same fashion. May Christ richly
bless you in the grace and peace won by
him and his vicarious death on the cross
for sinners. Hallelujah and Marinatha.
[Music]